quoique sinon bonjour à tous qui est
venant kpata gamme et si jay lerner
mathias et cette semaine dans mon
reportage je vous parle des élections
municipales
pour ce qui était peut-être au courant
le 7 novembre prochaine donc ce dimanche
ce sera jour d'élections municipales
dans l'ensemble des municipalités au
québec et j'avais envie d'aborder
certains sujets certaines thématiques
avez-vous d'abord je voulais porter à
votre attention une situation
particulière dont j'ai pris connaissance
dernièrement et c'est le fait que ce
dimanche
quand ce sera jour d'élection mais il ya
des membres des premières nations qui
habitent dans des communautés
autochtones qui vont pouvoir se
prévaloir de leur droit de vote mais
dans les municipalités voisines donc ces
gens là sans qu'ils habitent le
territoire des municipalités en question
parce qu'ils habitent en communauté ils
vont pouvoir se prévalant de droits de
vote et voter pour les représentants de
la ville ce qui explique cette situation
particulière c'est que au sein du
gouvernement donc dans le ministère qui
s'occupe du découpage des territoires
des municipalités pour les élections
municipales c'est comme si on y intégrer
le territoire de certaines communautés
autochtones dans celui de la ville et ça
c'est quand même une situation qui est
particulière et quand même problématique
parce que c'est comme si on venait à un
peu remettre en doute remettre en
question l'intégrité territoriale des
communautés autochtones il ya plusieurs
conseils de bande de communauté qui
dénoncent cette situation là en disant
que
ça devrait pas être le cas les membres
dans les communautés ne devrait pas
recevoir leur carte d'électeur pour les
municipalités voisines est-ce que les
contrées de bandes avance c'est qu'en
fait ce sont eux les légitimes
représentants des mondes qui habitent
dans les communautés sur le territoire
des communautés dans certains cas dans
le coran trop de la communauté innue à
stuttgart sur lac saint jean ça fait
maintenant plus de dix ans qui dénoncent
cette situation là auprès du
gouvernement etc il s'est même pas la
faute de la ville de roberval que la
ville voisine parce que le autant la
ville de roberval et autant la
municipalité mash up sont d'accord pour
dire que c'est une situation qui ne fait
aucun sens en fait le la balle est dans
le camp du gouvernement et pour des
raisons x ou y aurait rien qui s'est
fait encore depuis dix
ans dépenses à ce que je trouve vraiment
intéressant c'est qu'on a des membres
des communautés
qui se disent mais pourquoi ne pas
saisir cette opportunité
pourquoi ne pas profiter peut-être de
cette faille dans le système pour aller
voter aux élections des municipalités
qui sont voisines pour peut-être
influencer le vote d'une certaine façon
pour favoriser l'élection par exemple
deux candidats qui sont peut-être plus
ouverts aux plus sensibles aux enjeux
des premières neiges et ça je trouve
vraiment intéressant il y en a même qui
pousse sont encore plus loin en stand by
nous on va se présenter aux élections
soit comme conseiller soit comme maire
c'est le cas notamment dans la ville de
la tâche point sur la côte nord ou
encore dans la municipalité de la force
au témiscamingue où est-ce qu'on a des
membres des premières nations qui sont
dit maintenant on va se présenter pour
être des élus de ces villes le haut de
ses 2 ces municipalités au village le et
dernière savez il ya une volonté de
réconciliation de la part des candidats
qui se disent bien qui de mieux que des
autochtones pourparlers pour les
autochtones et peut-être apporter notre
point de vue et nous en jeu à la table
des conseils de vieux pour pouvoir
éventuellement peut-être créer des
partenariats ou d entendre de façon plus
facile peut-être temps que les
municipalités et les communautés
autochtones
derrière tout ça moi ce que j'en
comprends c'est que je vois une espèce
de de prise de conscience d'apport des
individus autochtone par rapport au
pouvoir qu'ils ont on sait pendant
longtemps le taux de votation des
autochtones aux élections que ce soit
fédérales provinciales ou municipales il
était somme toute assez beau et depuis
quelques temps j'ai l'impression que que
les autochtones prennent conscience du
pouvoir qu'ils ont pris du poids qu'ils
peuvent avoir dans la balance lors
d'élections donc pour moi ça c'est
porteur d'espoir parce que on a notre
mot à dire c'est peut-être qu'en prenant
cette place là en allant voter en
montrant qu'on est présents qui
conseille intéresse aux enjeux mais
peut-être qu'on veut nous écouter
davantage et j'aimerais conclure en
invitant mais mes frères et soeurs
autochtone aller voter ce dimanche lors
des élections municipales et ce mec que
vous habitiez en ville où que vous
habitiez en communauté autochtone fait
valoir votre voix et influencer le vois
de positiver sur ce je vous souhaite un
très bon week-end et à bientôt bien